[موسيقى]
بدنا فعاليات موسم الرياض احتضن معرض وانا
عربيه اكثر من 200 مصممه من مختلف الدول
العربيه
[موسيقى]
منها في التعريف عن نفسها وعن علامتها
التجاريه الجديده
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاركتي هنا هي بحد ذاتها تسويق
لمنتجاتنا لان المعرض مثل ما انت عارفه
جدا راقي جدا كلاس وعلى مستوى الوطن
العربي مش على مستوى الخليج فقط
فبالنسبه لنا هذا نجاح
يعني في مسيرتنا
[موسيقى]
ومن الازياء الى المجوهرات التي صممت
خصيصا للمعرض بقطع لا تتواجد على منصات
المصممات الالكترونيه كما كانت الاواني
الفاخره زينه المعرض في مختلف ارجائه
[موسيقى]
المعرض كثير حلو
مثل العاده اهل السعوديه
[موسيقى]
معرض وانا عربيه يجمع بين الفخامه والفن
والابداع ويتضمن ايضا فقرات موسيقيه
تعزفها فتيات عربيه اضافه الى عزف عود
يطرب زائري المعرض من الرياض شهد متروك
العربيه